hi i'm charlotte fraser a second year
phd student in computational
neuroscience and i want to give you some
tips and tricks to be more effective so
today i wanted to talk about the law of
triviality or one of the laws of
parkinson's so he talks about this
effect that when there is a meeting or
any type of discussions people tend to
spend most of their time on the trivial
issue and not really focus on the main
issue at hand what uh what can i do for
you i'm heading the design team that's
building the enclosure for the box it's
time for the concept meeting
concept meeting
okay
i'm just gonna show you a few pictures
and you tell me which ones you like okay
okay sure
so parkinson's gave this example of the
building of a nuclear power plant and
the committee that had to do that they
actually didn't spend any time on the
discussion of safety or how to build
this nuclear power plant or where it
should be built but they actually spend
the majority of the time on the
construction of the bike shed next to
the power plant and if you've ever been
in any meetings you probably will
recognize this effect that we spend a
majority on our time on these trivial
issues and there are a lot of reasons
why we do it it's because it's easier
for everyone to understand and usually
everyone can contribute something to
this discussion have any ideas what we
could do
any suggestions yes handy what if we
changed our outgoing answering machine
message
so it just had a little more
zing and a little more pep
zing and pep see that's those are the
kind of words we're looking for yes jim
what about if we did an even newer
voicemail message that had even more
singing now we're cooking whereas the
harder discussion is usually avoided
because it is very hard but the problem
is if you are in a work environment or
you are a phd student you have to do a
lot of work so these kind of meetings
can really eat up your time and that's
why i want to give you three tips today
as to how to avoid these kind of
discussions meetings or how to make them
a little bit more productive for you so
the first tip i have comes from the book
from calm newport deep work and he just
says basically to try to avoid any type
of meetings or tasks where this kind of
triviality is present so for example in
our research institute we have these big
meetings for the whole institute and
they can take up to three hours and we
discuss everything from management
issues to the food at the cafeteria and
i know a lot of people go to these
meetings but i find them really
unproductive so i don't have the
tendency to go to those meetings because
i think if you want to hang out with
your colleagues for example lunchtime is
way better or if you really want to
solve some issues it's better to do it
in a smaller team with about five people
and these really big meetings can just
eat up your time and another big thing
is for example emails i think if you
work in some kind of university settings
you know that there can be these endless
email streams from different people and
i think in general to just answer really
shortly or to just ignore most of the
emails is actually way more beneficial
for your workflow than to really be on
top of all your emails at all time
because usually people solve their own
problems if you give them a little bit
of time and don't respond straight away
and i also think by responding straight
away you usually create more questions
and i do have to say there is a little
caveat because of course if your
professor is emailing you you have to
answer straight away and the second tip
i want to give is if you know you have
some meetings that you have to attend or
that you really want something answered
i would try to beforehand kind of curate
the amount of time you want to spend on
certain questions and also to have a
main question that you want answered
such that when you go into the
discussion you can kind of stare the
discussion back to this main question
when people tend to diverge a little bit
jan director inside sales they call me
jan the man yes we know jan the man
listen uh
we have to do neural net for deep
learning look once we get enough data
flowing through the system it will be
able to recognize long-range patterns
and actually learn and by doing this you
can make your discussions a lot more
productive you can get a lot out of it
and you can also see where people tend
to diverge and avoid those moments and
the last tip i have is something i
learned from ali abdull and he says it's
really conductive to have a daily
highlight and i kind of agree with this
because in your work you have a tendency
to first finish the small easy tasks and
to put off the main big task but if you
set a daily intention of one big task
that you want to finish or at least work
on for a few hours that day i notice in
myself that i have less of the tendency
to focus on these little small tasks so
for example today i wanted to finish
this coding project and replicate a
certain finding from a certain paper and
it actually took me a lot longer than i
anticipated but because i started in the
morning with this task i had it finished
by the end of the day whereas normally
if i didn't set this daily intention i
probably would have procrastinated until
the end of the day and wouldn't have
finished it so these were my three tips
on the law of triviality if you have any
interesting stories or of weird meetings
you had leave them down in the comments
below and i also made a little video of
how to deal with stress and anxiety
during your phd so you can check that
out here and otherwise see you next week
bye